In this segment, we
pursue two themes.
Every concept has a conditional
counterpart.
We know about PDFs, but if
we live in a conditional
universe, then we deal with
conditional probabilities.
And we need to use
conditional PDFs.
The second theme is that
discrete formulas have
continuous counterparts in which
summations get replaced
by integrals, and
PMFs by PDFs.
So let us recall the definition
of a conditional
PMF, which is just the same as
an ordinary PMF but applied to
a conditional universe.
In the same spirit, we can start
with a PDF, which we can
interpret, for example, in
terms of probabilities of
small intervals.
If we move to a conditional
model in which event A is
known to have occurred,
probabilities of small
intervals will then be
determined by a conditional
PDF, which we denote
in this manner.
Of course, we need to assume
throughout that the
probability of the conditioning
event is positive
so that conditional
probabilities are
well-defined.
Let us now push the
analogy further.
We can use a PMF to calculate
probabilities.
The probability that X takes [a]
value in a certain set is
the sum of the probabilities
of all the possible
values in that set.
And a similar formula is true
if we're dealing with a
conditional model.
Now, in the continuous case, we
use a PDF to calculate the
probability that X takes values
in a certain set.
And by analogy, we use a
conditional PDF to calculate
conditional probabilities.
We can take this relation here
to be the definition of a
conditional PDF.
So a conditional PDF is a
function that allows us to
calculate probabilities by
integrating this function over
the event or set of interest.
Of course, probabilities
need to sum to 1.
This is true in the
discrete setting.
And by analogy, it should
also be true in
the continuous setting.
This is just an ordinary PDF,
except that it applies to a
model in which event A is
known to have occurred.
But it still is a
legitimate PDF.
It has to be non-negative,
of course.
But also, it needs to
integrate to 1.
When we condition on an event
and without any further
assumption, there's not much we
can say about the form of
the conditional PDF.
However, if we condition on an
event of a special kind, that
X takes values in a certain
set, then we can actually
write down a formula.
So let us start with a random
variable X that has a given
PDF, as in this diagram.
And suppose that A is a subset
of the real line, for example,
this subset here.
What is the form of the
conditional PDF?
We start with the interpretation
of PDFs and
conditional PDFs in terms of
probabilities of small intervals.
The probability that X lies in
a small interval is equal to
the value of the PDF somewhere
in that interval times the
length of the interval.
And if we're dealing with
conditional probabilities,
then we use the corresponding
conditional PDF.
To find the form of the
conditional PDF, we will work
in terms of the left-hand side
in this equation and try to
rewrite it.
Let us distinguish two cases.
Suppose that little X lies
somewhere out here, and we
want to evaluate the conditional
PDF at that point.
So trying to evaluate this
expression, we consider a
small interval from little
x to little x plus delta.
And now, let us write the
definition of a conditional
probability.
A conditional probability, by
definition, is equal to the
probability that both events
occur divided by the
probability of the conditioning
event.
Now, because the set A and
this little interval are
disjoint, these two events
cannot occur simultaneously.
So the numerator here
is going to be 0.
And this will imply that
the conditional PDF is
also going to be 0.
This, of course, makes sense.
Conditioned on the event that
X took values in this set,
values of X out here
cannot occur.
And therefore, the conditional
density out here
should also be 0.
So the conditional PDF is 0
outside the set A. And this
takes care of one case.
Now, the second case to consider
is when little x lies
somewhere inside here inside the
set A. And in that case,
our little interval from little
x to little x plus
delta might have this form.
In this case, the intersection
of these two events, that X
lies in the big set and X lies
in the small set, the
intersection of these two events
is the event that X
lies in the small set.
So the numerator simplifies just
to the probability that
the random variable X takes
values in the interval from
little x to little
x plus delta.
And then we rewrite
the denominator.
Now, the numerator is just an
ordinary probability that the
random variable takes values
inside a small interval.
And by our interpretation of
PDFs, this is approximately
equal to the PDF evaluated
somewhere in that small
interval times delta.
At this point, we notice that
we have deltas on both sides
of this equation.
By cancelling this delta with
that delta, we finally end up
with a relation that the
conditional PDF should be
equal to this expression
that we have here.
So to summarize, we have
shown a formula for
the conditional PDF.
The conditional PDF is 0 for
those values of X that cannot
occur given the information that
we are given, namely that
X takes values at
that interval.
But inside this interval, the
conditional PDF has a form
which is proportional to
the unconditional PDF.
But it is scaled by a
certain constant.
So in terms of a picture,
we might have
something like this.
And so this green diagram
is the form of
the conditional PDF.
The particular factor that we
have here in the denominator
is exactly that factor that is
required, the scaling factor
that is required so that the
total area under the green
curve, under the conditional
PDF is equal to 1.
So we see once more the
familiar theme, that
conditional probabilities
maintain the same relative
sizes as the unconditional
probabilities.
And the same is true for
conditional PMFs or PDFs,
keeping the same shape as the
unconditional ones, except
that they are re-scaled so that
the total probability
under a conditional
PDF is equal to 1.
We can now continue the same
story and revisit everything
else that we had done for
discrete random variables.
For example, we have the
expectation of a discrete
random variable and the
corresponding conditional
expectation, which is just the
same kind of object, except
that we now rely on conditional
probabilities.
Similarly, we can take the
definition of the expectation
for the continuous case and
define a conditional
expectation in the same manner,
except that we now
rely on the conditional PDF.
So this formula here is the
definition of the conditional
expectation of a continuous
random variable given a
particular event.
We have a similar situation with
the expected value rule,
which we have already seen for
discrete random variables in
both of the unconditional and
in the conditional setting.
We have a similar formula
for the continuous case.
And at this point, you can
guess the form that the
formula will take in the
continuous conditional setting.
This is the expected value
rule in the conditional
setting, and it is proved
exactly the same way as for
the unconditional continuous
setting, except that here in
the proof, we need to work with
conditional probabilities
and conditional PDFs, instead
of the unconditional ones.
So to summarize, there is
nothing really different when
we condition on an event in the
continuous case compared
to the discrete case.
We just replace summations
with integrations.
And we replace PMFs by PDFs.